madame la présidente madame la ministre
messieurs les présidents de commissions
madame et Messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues après deux semaines de
débats riches et intenses je suis fier
de me retrouver à nouveau devant vous
pour défendre l'adoption d'un texte
crucial pour l'avenir énergétique et
écologique de la France
cruciale tout d'abord pour préserver
notre planète des effets du dérèglement
climatique à l'oeuvre chaque année plus
menaçant à ce titre nous avons veillé
tout au long de ce texte à articuler les
enjeux climatiques à ceux de
préservation de la biodiversité nos
politiques publiques doivent se
coordonner et ignorer en rien les liens
étroits entre climat et biodiversité
crucial ensuite au regard de notre
souveraineté car nous ne pouvons pas
accepter que notre consommation
d'énergie finale dépendent toujours plus
actuellement aux deux tiers des énergies
fossiles produites par des puissances
étrangères l'actualité récente nous
rappelle l'urgence de garantir notre
indépendance et notre autonomie
énergétique
ces deux semaines de débats ont démontré
la richesse de notre assemblée et
l'existence d'un chemin celui d'un
travail transpartisan au service des
Français près de la moitié des
amendements adoptés sur ce texte
proviennent des groupes d'opposition je
tiens donc à féliciter avec force madame
la ministre pour sa capacité d'écoute sa
détermination à trouver des compromis et
donc son sens de l'intérêt collectif
nous avons donc construit un texte
équilibré qui permettra de déployer au
plus vite le potentiel de nos
territoires en matière d'énergie
renouvelables aussi nombreuses
soient-elles en effet il est impératif
de diversifier nos modes de production
renouvelables en développant davantage
la méthanisation la géothermie
l'hydrogène ou les réseaux de chaleur et
de froid il faut accélérer partout où
cela est possible ce texte permet de
réduire efficacement les délais pour la
mise en oeuvre des projets d'énergie
renouvelables grâce à une simplification
des profites procédures sans toutefois
escamotée l'indispensable participation
du public participation à laquelle notre
groupe est attaché
5 ans pour la construction d'un parc
solaire 7 pour un parc éolien terrestre
10 pour un parc éolien en mer ces
chiffres seront bientôt obsolètes et
fortement réduit grâce à ce texte pour
cela l'accélération des projets par
l'échelon le plus local et la clé le
national doit fixer le cap les objectifs
informés des potentiels énergétiques de
chacun et puis c'est aux élus locaux
d'être au cœur du dispositif de cette
planification énergétique il en
reviendra ainsi d'identifier les zones
les plus propices pour accueillir des
projets d'énergie renouvelables car qui
de mieux placé pour le savoir si la
proposition sénatoriale du veto des mers
n'était pas une bonne solution les
maires n'en voulaient d'ailleurs pas
eux-mêmes je le dis clairement aucune
zone d'accélération ne pourrait être
identifiée sans la vie conforme de la
commune concernée l'éolien en mer
également bénéficiera en fin d'une
planification permettant de rattraper
son retard
de planification sera prévue sur 10 ans
pour les quatre façades maritimes
notamment grâce à une cartographie qui
permettra d'identifier les zones
d'accélération à horizon 2050 nous
sommes bien sûr conscients de la
nécessité de favoriser l'acceptabilité
des éoliennes en mer c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons renforcé la
possibilité de saisir la Commission
nationale du débat public sur l'éolien
nous pouvons enfin nous réjouir d'avoir
introduit des mesures pour la
préservation de la biodiversité marine
concernant le déploiement de l'énergie
solaire le groupe démocrate se satisfait
de l'ambition apportée pour la
libération du foncier comme par exemple
l'extension de l'obligation pour les
parkings extérieurs existants
d'installer des panneaux solaires ou
encore en bordure d'autoroute et de
voies ferrées je tiens à ce titre à
saluer le travail de notre rapporteur
haut de Luquet nous sommes également
satisfaits des mesures votées contre en
concernant pardon la grille voltaïsme il
était essentiel d'encadrer ces pratiques
en les conditionnant une activité
agricole ces choses faites en outre nous
avons obtenu quel état fixer un volume
de surface pouvant être mobilisés pour
le solaire au sol de la même manière une
installation photovoltaïque ne pourra
pas être possible au sol sans avoir été
préalablement mis en place sur une
surface de 40% minimum en toiture ces
installations ne seront autorisées que
sur des terres réputés incultes ou non
exploités depuis au moins 10 ans dans le
but de permettre le déploiement des
énergies renouvelables sans menacer la
production agricole avec aussi des
garanties financières pour s'assurer de
la réversibilité des installations
agrivoltaïques non seulement aussi
l'adoption du meilleur partage de la
valeur créée par l'exploitation des ENR
qui permettra aux communes développement
des projets de voir leur facture baissée
ou d'en tirer des ressources pour
financer des projets de rénovation
énergétique ce texte largement
co-construit avec les groupes
d'opposition apporte ainsi une réponse
pragmatique et ambitieuse au défi imposé
par le dérèglement climatique et c'est
avec beaucoup de fierté que le groupe
démocrate le votera madame la ministre
si les républicains et le rassemblement
national j'en finis madame la Présidente
le rassemblement national votre
rencontre par dogmatisme anti-olien
J'espère de tout cœur que nos colocs de
gauche soutiendront ou à tout le moins
n'empêcheront pas la doption de ce texte
auquel ces membres ont largement
contribué j'espère que vous aussi
collègues écologiste malgré votre
annonce de la semaine dernière qui m'a
surprise vous votre respect que vous
avez contribué à écrire avec l'adoption
de plus d'une trentaine d'amendements je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]